hey guys dr. Berg here I had a lot of requests
for honey okay raw honey versus pasteurized honey
so let's just talk about it it takes 60,000
bees 55,000 miles to make one pound of honey
and then we steal their honey okay we give them
sugar water it's just terrible but honey in the
right form is very antimicrobial anti-inflammatory
and especially if you mix it with a little apple
cider vinegar and lemon and water you know
it can help you anti-allergy why because it
has pollen and has other factors that really
will help build up your immune system and even
can lower blood pressure and it has B vitamins
magnesium calcium potassium says basically it's
a sweetener that has a lot of good stuff however
it still has 50% fructose in 50% glucose which
means it can flow down your weight loss and it
does have a relatively high glycemic index now
there are certain types of honey especially with
Tupelo honey that is much lower and it's used
for diabetics and small small amounts so if you
want to consume honey for certain health reasons
the version that I would consume would be the
manuka honey okay find that because because it's
a really unprocessed raw honey that has a lot of
great properties but here's the thing make sure
your honey is always raw and it's not pasteurized
why because when they pasteurizer they cook it to
destroy everything it so now you're just getting
pure sugar now yes it's true that if here you're
not going to give raw honey to a baby because
there's a risk of getting botulism and by the way
my son when you were six months old got botulism
not from honey from some other source but it can
be very very scary and dangerous so you don't want
to give small infants but if you're adult you can
get away with it very easily but so my overall
impression honey is that it's really the quality
make sure it's raw and and go ahead and have some
if you're trying to improve your allergies or your
immune system and you want to do this on like
a periodic basis all right thanks for watching